hello everyone and welcome today's live
broadcast using network models to
understand common complex disease
predispositions and progression
presented by our keynote speaker dr.
Kenneth Bhutto director of the
computational sciences and informatics
program for complex adaptive systems at
Arizona State University and professor
in the School of Life Sciences and asu's
College of Liberal Arts and Sciences
where your moderators Jacob Gentile and
we are delighted to bring you an
educational web seminars presented by
lab roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left corner of the presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appears in the screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button on the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let them know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the button in
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
please join me in welcoming dr. Butte oh
thank you very much Jacob and Chantal as
was indicated I'm Ken Vito I'm a
professor in the School of Life Sciences
at Arizona State University and I'm
going to be talking today about how we
are doing novel work applying Network
models to try to understand the
underlying etiology and origins of
common complex diseases predisposition
and progression I want to begin by my
disclosures I am an adviser to
bristol-myers Squibb immuno oncology
community oncology program but have no
relevant disclosures or financial
relationships associated with this
presentation so what does this talk
about it essentially leverages the
passion of my professional research
career for almost 30 years I've been
exploring through my research team along
with the rest of the scientific
community the question of what drives
common disease etiology and outcomes for
example we know large-scale epidemic
emerging in the developed world for
diabesity we can see the United States
for instance we're anticipating having
23 million cases of diabetes in the in
the upcoming currently and in the
upcoming decade but more alarming is
when we look worldwide at common
diseases in the developing nation we see
there is a tremendous expansion of the
presence and prevalence of these
diseases in China anticipated to be 90
million cases in India 61 million cases
through public health crisis that we
actually are still struggling with as a
biomedical community knowing too what to
do with what the source of these is and
how we might successfully intervene so
let's focus from moment on obesity
obesity is arguably a precursor
condition of diabetes and many of these
complex traits but we also recognize
that morbidity and mortality for
something like obesity is driven not
only by having this disease itself but
by the sequela that emerge after one has
obesity the development of type 2
diabetes of liver disease of
cardiovascular disease and cancer are
actually the real tremendous morbid and
mortal risk factors associated with
having these types of diseases
what provocative and interesting though
is that when we look at obesity we see
that different individuals progress down
different paths not everyone that is
obese goes on to develop any out on any
additional sequela
others the want to develop type 2
diabetes and what we see is very non
random patterns very non-random paths by
which many of these complex diseases
evolve to increasingly greater morbidity
and ultimately mortality shown here for
instance on this slide is the
progression from obesity to type-2
diabetes to non-alcoholic
steatohepatitis test pad of cellular
carcinoma what is it that drives
different individuals down different
morbid paths we know a lot in 2017 about
diseases like obesity shown on this
slide is a diagram from the foresight
project in the UK where all of the
etiologic components have been mapped
that try to show what drives different
individuals in different circumstances
to have obesity at the core of this
diagram is well recognized phenomenon
related to physical activity energy
maintenance energy acquisition but what
we actually recognize is that this core
concept is much more embedded in this
much more complicated Network this
morass of interacting factors that
amplify this effect we also know that
these factors are distributed among a
variety of different social and
developmental context we see that for
instance that there are many dynamic
evolving components that drive the
origin and outcome of obesity that are
not just this core central metabolic
framework of energy acquisition and
energy expenditure but other complicated
facets the challenges of these of course
is that these facets when we look at
psychology and physiology and food
consumptions are dynamic they change
over time they change within an
individual from time to time they change
not only within time but they actually
change as you age so the study of how to
approach this or the capacity to be able
to integrate all this information
becomes very difficult because of the
ever-changing
dynamic when do we study a person or do
we actually have the practical capacity
to study someone from cradle to grave
so my group has been interested in
taking a different approach rather than
this larger integrated framework is to
start with these phenotypes and then to
utilize the underlying inherited DNA
variation our motivation for using this
underlying DNA variation is it's among
all of these other contributing factors
to obesity it's the one that is
relatively constant from cradle to grave
your inherited DNA variability genomic
DNA variability pattern is your DNA
pattern from the time you're born till
largely till the time you die so it's
the one constant that we can look at
across this entire complex continuum now
that said we're further encouraged that
studying inherited variability may turn
out to be an important contributor to
these traits by recognizing that each of
these traits have very high delightedly
high heritability the fraction of total
variance of the traits attributable to
inherited genetic variation we can look
at traits such as obesity that have
argued to have somewhere between 40 to
70% heritability the variability of this
trait due to the inherited Constitution
your inherited genetic Constitution type
2 diabetes again 30 to 70% heritability
very large fractions attributable to
this genetic variation and even cancers
one of the outcome cancers that's along
the path of obesity to type 2 diabetes
through liver disease to Apatow cellular
carcinoma or HCC itself has over 10%
heritability so there in theory are very
strong genetic signals underpinning
these traits that we should be able to
find so with great enthusiasm my group
as well as much of the genetics and
genomics community have gone on
large-scale genetic genome-wide
Association study searches
to find the variability that underpins
these complex common complex diseases
shown here is a standard Manhattan plots
on a somewhat recent nature paper
showing up the identification of this
constitutional variation is associated
in this instance with breast cancer
another obesity associated cancer but
what we've seen as we conducted more and
more of these studies is disheartening
we've found that when we find these
individual loci on these Manhattan plots
that they have very small effects
commonly odds ratios of 1.1 barely above
significance and with again large enough
sample sizes almost anything can be
detected but the influence of any
individual low side or locus is quite
small these highly associated snips are
not observed commonly across studies in
fact while one can conduct very large
meta-analysis and find
interrelationships if you look at study
to study very rarely it's the unusual
case that you will find a snip that's
highly associated and is reproducible
across studies moreover what we find is
that the fraction of this heritability
even when we've done these genome-wide
snip assessments with increasingly high
resolution of genetic analysis that
there's a very small fraction of this
heritability that I just mentioned being
described so here's a concrete example
for the three examples that I showed a
moment ago so in obesity its
optimistically estimated that we're
explaining maybe 20% of the total
heritability type-2 diabetes
embarrassingly even less less than 5% of
the total heritability explained by our
common genome-wide studies and when we
look at cancer as well this specific
form of cancer have a cellular carcinoma
that's associated with obesity and type
2 diabetes
we see that back to a very small less
let less than 20 little over 20 percent
of the variance
explained so arguably by at least common
contemporary standards we might describe
this as an epic fail so why why why are
we failing so miserably in these studies
well some of this is predictable from
what we actually know a lot about
population genetics evolutionary history
of populations as well as the underlying
biology that is not being captured in
these genome-wide Association studies so
we know that there's heterogeneity
etiology due to local adaptation and
drift and we also know that we're not
formally capturing in these genome-wide
Association studies the underlying
biologic mechanisms that drive these
patterns of variation so let me start
with what I mean by local app
adaptations to environmental challenges
we tend when we study these types of
phenomena Stu assume that all humans
have the identical genetic Constitution
and that there is little or no variation
that we can consider all humans to be
essentially the same as inbred
laboratory mice well unfortunately
that's just simply not true humans over
their course of evolutionary time have
repeatedly adapted to their local
environments perhaps the best understood
example of this is studying
hemoglobinopathies with the slides shown
here where we can see that across the
cross the cost of world in high malarial
areas there have been repeated
adaptations to extreme environments that
generate heterogeneity in the underlying
genetics of this particular trait so
there is not a single human variant
associated with malaria or in response
to malaria but a whole a whole
collection literally a dozen or more
individual adaptations that have
occurred independently over evolutionary
time that actually would not be easily
detected in the current frame of the
types of studies that are being done
with G wasps here's another example this
where we look at not just
malaria but we're in this instance we
look at all sorts of adaptations to
environment but again a recurring rule
is that there is local adaptation that
has occurred in in response to common
environmental activities so in this
instance highlighted here is the
distribution worldwide distribution of
specific different genes associated with
adaptation to high altitude so over the
course of human evolution during the
time of human evolution what we've seen
then is that this pressure has generated
multiple solutions to the same problem
of high altitude let's go back for a
second now though and also now look at
malaria again in this instance that
pressure associated with malaria I
showed the modifications in the first
series of slides for this in respect to
beta globin but what we can see is there
have been other adaptations over and
above what has happened with beta globin
and hemoglobin in response to malaria
let's focus for instance on two like a
four and a and like the four and B again
two adaptations that have occurred
arguably or have been argued to be in
response to malaria so like a poor and
an B actually are captured commonly in
cero typing in the MNS blood group and
what we can see here now is the
worldwide distribution of those so again
as we start to look at genetic etiology
of something complex and common like
obesity or diabetes then it's not
completely surprising that we are going
to see heterogeneity in the underlying
patterns of particular variants so shown
here for those of you who might not
remember the genetics occurred before
the advent of DNA sequencing this is
worldwide distribution of blood group
typing by Morant and I'm going to refer
to more of his work in just a second but
we can see radically different
distributions of risk alleles or the
alleles that evolved in response to
malaria in different populations with
the M group being very high in the
Americas and actually being very low in
the
African subcontinent what we also see is
not only do we have these multiple
independent variants in a locus or there
or variants occurring in different
low-side but we also see that in some
instances from the paper here in fan
actually the sorry this isn't
highlighting well if we look to that
third or fourth panel down we can see
that some of the variation is
attributable to polygenic inheritance so
if we put a circle around there what we
can see is that many of these traits in
order to actually be responsive to
environment don't occur just don't
require modifications in a single locus
but require modifications in multiple
loci in order to produce their response
to the phenotype we also know that this
heterogeneity is an Clyde when I showed
them the MNS blood group across the
world but we know that there is
tremendous heterogeneity even in
populations that we consider to be
common so let me focus for a second here
on a class that's routinely used in jiwa
studies people of European descent or
even people of Northern European descent
are considered to be a common contrast
group that we can assemble the groups
for so here we're going to focus again
on a common variant that that we know
the DNA basis of in 2017 but that again
was described in detail by the marantz
in 1954 we can see that if we look at
the [ __ ] blood group here one that almost
everyone here probably know is there
tides that's participating in this or
that's monitoring this talk and we can
see that the assumption that we can look
at Europeans as a common community if we
just look at the a allele of the [ __ ]
blood group isn't violently violated we
can see that there's relatively high
homogeneity across Northern Europe
especially if we exclude the populations
of high northern latitude
however this gets a little more dicey if
we actually now look at the distribution
of B across Europe we can see that in
fact this northern European group is
longer quite as hetero G quite as
homogeneous as what we saw with B and
when we actually start to move to the
Type O group we see that in fact there's
tremendous heterogeneity in the gene
frequency the allele frequency
associated with the O blood group so
what we can see is that even this
population for a common variant that we
actually know very well has tremendous
variation within a group that within a
group that we normally count on it being
homogeneous so why is that significant
well the challenge is then if we don't
account for that or don't have a way in
our analytic message to address this
then we artificially generate
associations and we will see differences
that we're scribing to places and
controls because we have slight
differences for instance if we're using
europeans slight differences whether we
have how many germans we have in our
population versus how many french we
have in our population we will get
significant differences especially with
the ultra high sample sizes that we're
using in today's g law studies these
minor differences will all turn out to
be highly significant but not
reproducible study to study because of
the variation between the different
populations and the different studies so
there's one other and this is one of the
key factors that we're interested in
exploring and that's that we're not
measuring interaction so we have the
population history population genetics
and population dynamics that drive or
challenge us doing these types of
identification studies but we also have
the challenge that were not embracing
the biology associated with many of
these trees traits so I've mentioned
certainly that many of these traits are
polygenic but they're even more than
polygenic they actually work complex
phenotypes are products of biologic
networks they are emergent properties of
multiple changes that are occurring in
complex biologic processes that are
captured in network
and these networks are what drive
specific phenotypes I actually love this
TS Eliot quote that actually captures
who I think we are currently in our
single independent snip evaluation we're
sort of caught in this hell of
disconnected data that if we actually
look at the data through the lens of
interconnected networks biologic
processes or biologic pathways that may
give us insight now the cancer community
at least the somatic genetics cancer
community is has embraced this now for
almost a decade
part of lis out of necessity it became
very clear with large-scale projects
like the Cancer Genome Atlas and other
class projects that the was not
coherence to the datasets unless we
integrated what was being observed in
cancer mutations at the level of
networks and when we assemble the data
in these networks what we saw is that
suddenly data that looked remarkably
noisy and chaotic very coherent with us
having the capacity to assemble all of
these mutations into common pathways so
what we've been doing in our group now
then is using this network framework as
a primary analytic routine now I don't
want to say the jiwa studies after they
have done their individual sniff
analysis don't commonly look to see if
networks are over represented by the
significant snips they found what we're
doing is upfront
starting with collections of snips in
networks and then analyzing the network
to see whether the distribution is
different of the snips within a network
then one would expect by chance alone or
that that distribution differs between
cases and controls so the advantage of
using this network analysis is that it
both integrates the regional
heterogeneity in disease risk modifying
low-side so in other words if you in
these adaptations that I showed in
earlier slides have modified variants in
different components of these biologic
processes in order to accomplish your
modified phenotype this will now be
capped
in the network analysis it also captures
the interaction information so it's been
argued that the missing heritability in
genomic studies is that we're not
capturing the interaction terms between
the individual snips that amplify the
effects of the individual snips when we
look over and above what we would see if
we looked at their marginal frequencies
independently then tactically one of the
attractive things of this is we look at
them instead of having to look at a
million snips or two million snips or
three million snips we look at
twenty-five hundred biologic processes
so we actually increase our power and
reduce the dimensionality of the
investigations that we're attempting to
explore
so the key methodology that I'm going to
describe in the results that I'm
presenting today is an extension of the
work initially published by Rosemary
Bron while she was a postdoc at the
National Cancer Institute called the
pathways of distinction analysis a
technique for combining multi snip
analysis using G wasps data in this
particular work we use a distance based
metric where we essentially calculate
the distance between cases and controls
using the Met Network is the assembly
proxy of this variability under the
assumption that individuals who have a
genetically based trait and now remember
all the traits we looked at have high
heritability somewhere between 30 to 70%
heritability they should have network or
they should have genetic underlying
contributions to their variability that
those who have the trait should have a
different distribution of their genetic
variability than those who do not and we
use a distance metric in order to
quantify that so in this instance for
those of you who are interested in the
technical details I'd point you directly
to rosemarys paper but the distance
statistic was initially derived by Homer
at all for solving a forensics problem
but it's actually relatively simple
conceptually we just look at each
individual
and then measure their distance from
cases that controls and summarize this
across all of the low sigh in individual
networks so this is stated in words what
this looks like perhaps a picture is
easier to conceptualize so that distance
metric that you see at the top is
essentially just looking for each
individual in our study and measuring
their distance their genetic distance
from cases and controls and then
standardizes it showing in a
standardized fashion so we can compare
across individual pathways and
statistics are evaluated either with the
pathway of distinction score where we
look specifically at a pathway or we use
the distance metric and calculate odds
ratios and use again bootstrapping and
permutation tests to adjust the unrep
for the underlying non-normality of the
data resources so I want to talk about
in is now what we see when we actually
apply these to several complex traits
common complex traits so we've examined
data independent datasets that are
publicly available through DB gap for
both type 2 diabetes' we've obtained for
public datasets and for obesity where
we've obtained three publicly shared
datasets we also then have access from
previous work a collaborative data set
from our colleagues in Korea for
hepatocellular carcinoma and what we've
been done is apply these network metrics
to attempt to identify the underlying
networks pathways that may underpin
these complex traits so let me focus in
detail on the type 2 diabetes data set I
realize this may be difficult to read
other than it's the sort of obligatory
population genetics slide that describes
the pop the characteristics of the
populations but the key here is to
indicate that these are relatively large
case control study sets in each instance
in two of the data sets over a thousand
cases and controls to the other two are
somewhat smaller but still large enough
to be specific
specific hypotheses and what we then do
is use the genotyping of is available
through DB gap in these data sets to
evaluate the differences in these
networks so shown here is that key
result that we've obtained from this so
if we look across these these four
different data sets what we find is that
there are a minimum of ten pathways when
we order them by the ones that
contribute have the highest
differentiation by their odds ratios we
find that there are ten pathways ten
highly significant pathways across all
four data sets and those pathways are
summarized on this slide so you can see
the distinction scores and the odds
ratio is one of the things notable if we
focus on the low our odds ratio column
to begin with as we can see that we're
seeing significantly greater odds ratios
than we would see for any individual
snip and more pragmatically if we look
at this probability of these odd ratios
we see whopping lehigh significant when
we're integrating at this level so these
pathways include GPCR downstream
signaling pi/3 a KT signaling pathways
and cancers mapped a signaling focal
adhesion with signaling calcium
signaling htlv-1 they will transmit a
receptor and axon guidance and I'm going
to focus on two of these what do these
actually look like in our analyses so
let's focus first on axon guidance one
that you may not immediately think of
and I would actually share with you that
pathway names are probably as misleading
in some sense as gene names they
actually describe the original biologic
context but again a priori one wouldn't
expect axon guidance as a pathway
process itself to necessarily be driving
type 2 diabetes susceptibility so let's
try to look at a little more detail
what's involved with axon guidance in
our analysis so axon guidance is one of
the pathways that we've obtained from
tag I realize in this form it's very
hard to actually see these pathways but
part of what I want you to pick up from
this
the gestalt of this pathway so we're
asking that green boxes here indicate
that we actually had snips in the
specific genes that we could evaluate
paintings snips indicate that when we
took all of the genes in this pathway
and did a step down analysis these with
a minimum subset of genes or snips
within these genes that retain the
original odds ratios significance and
then the red genes I will talk to in a
minute are genes that overlap teams that
actually when we look across our ten
pathways are common across pathways so
you can see already in axon guidance
that it's a proper subset of these genes
just from the Gestalt of the paint that
drive the significance of this network
and interestingly there's substantial
overlap in this pathway with other
pathways so let's zoom in on one of the
components of this so you can see it in
a little bit more detail but also see
where this modular overlap starts to
occur in these networks so this box that
I just brought up here captures the
components that are arguably in axon
guidance part of the wind signaling
pathway as you can see here is then it's
a proper subset of these it turned out
to be significant with the step down
evaluation we can see interestingly
already genes that overlap from the
other pathways that they showed in these
red components so we see that one of the
components of axon signaling is the wind
signaling pathway itself we can also
look at another piece of the axon
guidance in this instance we look at
this segment here and what we see here
is that the map case signaling pathway
is also a piece or modules from the map
case signaling pathway are also part of
the axon guidance and again what we can
see is that it's a proper subset that
are significant and interestingly
even a smaller subset that appear to be
common across this and other members
this ten pathway set so let's look at
another pathway for a second another one
that you might not expect to be
important in type 2 diabetes
htlv1 infection again this is another
kegg pathway it's displayed in a similar
manner to what I mentioned a moment ago
let's drill into the sub components here
of this particular pathway what we can
see here interestingly is we do pick up
not surprisingly members of the wind
signaling pathway as well as the mapped
a signaling pathway but we also pick up
a new module as part of this htlv-1 unit
which is t-cell receptor signaling
pathways so what we can see is we're not
only looking at the basic cell
metabolism cell division self-control
processes but we're picking up genes and
units modules biologic modules that
appear to be guiding and important in
modulating immuno responses which many
people have been interested in with
respect to type 2 diabetes as as
thinking of it as related to an immune
disease so we'll look at another
component of this particular pathway so
in this instance we'll look at this unit
and what we can see key here again is
again we see other members of our
pathway but central to this is antigen
presentation antigen processing and
presentation again related in particular
and almost the yang to the C cell
signaling receptor yes so we can see
interesting handshakes and conceivable
mechanistic insights that are emerging
from seeing the Assembly of these
individual modules what's interesting if
we just take all of the individual genes
for our step down analysis of these 10
pathways there's 259 of these individual
genes what's fascinating is that these
259 genes themselves form a super
Network they are not working
independently of each other so even
though we describe this as 10 separate
networks what we can see is in fact this
is 1 mega Network this is one complex of
interacting genes that apparently are
driving
ability to type-2 diabetes and even more
provocatively if we then focus on those
genes that were observed in one or more
pathway we get 66 of 68 of those genes
forming a very tight network that
appears to define a common underlying
etiology across four different data sets
with respect to type-2 diabetes we can
actually look at these individuals
sixty-eight genes using an alternative
projection of the data and see what
other biologic functions of these 68
genes what are the key things that's
driving these kind of phenomena and what
we can see here then is that with this
gene ontology analysis not completely
surprising we see things like positive
regulation of gene expression negative
regulation of signaling regulation of
protein serine kinase and regulation of
response to stress we not surprised even
when we looked at our modules that we
saw that maybe one of the underlying
biologic frameworks that's driving type
2 diabetes is a being the response a
little more surprising though then is
that we find a significant pathway is
neurogenesis again we've had axon
guidance and now we also have
neurogenesis which is suggesting a
fascinating underlying etiologic pattern
and when we can speculate on later as to
what might be important or why are we
having common etiology to type 2
diabetes so keynotes of analyzing these
10 pathways the analysis that the
individual snip level does not identify
the canonical type 2 diabetes risk low
side using conventional G while
significant criteria so if we look at
these four data sets that were present
in DB gap they do not identify the
traditional type 2 diabetes canonical lo
site that these large scale meta
analyses have found so they're not
within our analysis or in the author's
original publication of these work these
canonical type 2 risk factors are though
represented
in the pathways when analyzed but not
necessarily in the most significant
pathways so it's not that the canonical
lo site are not present in our analysis
they are not the driving low sigh of our
common underlying network analysis
features so what we then did as I
mentioned is look at these networks not
only in type-2 diabetes but in three
independent obesity related data sets
that were again obtained from DB DB gap
for as publicly accessible datasets
interestingly if we look at these
datasets in contrast to the type 2
diabetes datasets we see substantial
overlap in the network modules in the
networks that are driving BMI as a as
well as type 2 diabetes now not all of
the pathways are represented in all of
the obesity datasets but we can see that
on average at least five of the ten
pathways and if we and look actually
there's an overall that all ten of them
in one or more of the datasets appear to
be represented what we can also see is
when we look at these BMI datasets they
also have much larger odds ratios
associated with distinguishing cases
from controls then you would see for
normal obesity producing individual
snips so these snips taken in network
context are telling us an amplified
story that distinguishes those from high
DMI with those with low BMI so what we
also saw looking at our disease
progression story so if we argue that
obesity progresses to type 2 diabetes
diet diabetes and that type 2 diabetes
can put you at risk for primary liver
cancer interestingly if we then look at
our liver cancer data set we can see
that as then an interesting number of
these highly significant pathway
type 2 diabetes also significantly
differentiate those who are going to
develop or are different between those
with liver cancer and those without
liver cancer so again back to our
original table that has the type 2
diabetes results this single column for
type 2 diabetes is when we just looked
at the data combined all four data sets
an estimated across using a common set
of estimates across all the data sets
but what we can see is seven of these
ten pathways also show high odds ratios
significantly high odds ratio all of
these are are when multiple comparisons
adjusted are highly significant but show
seven of these 10 pathways also appear
to be risk modulating not only in
obesity not only in type 2 by diabetes
but also in 8cc so when we actually did
look at the small subset of genes that
were that were common across the
pathways in liver cancer the seven
pathways we can see that those genes
themselves produce a network just the
same as what we saw in type 2 diabetes
so again the genetic underlying genetic
predisposition deliver cancer doesn't
appear to be random collections of genes
that the genome but in fact is assembled
collection of genes in a mega network
that appears to be producing a phenotype
but interestingly then we can look at
this small network and contrast it to
the network we saw with type 2 diabetes
and what we can see then is these
networks overlap they have touch points
they have key pivot points that would
interconnect your susceptibility to
diabetes and susceptibility to liver
cancer but don't completely overlap so
it would help us number one understand
at one level why some people progress
for disease and other people don't and
then may suggest to us who is on which
different progression paths depending
which portfolio of
using risk alleles you might have so you
may have risk alleles that would put you
at risk for type 2 diabetes following
obesity and risk alleles that would put
you at risk for HCC following type 2
diabetes but don't necessarily have all
of them all the time you would have to
have these unique combinations in order
to make that full progression from
obesity to morbidity and mortality in
liver cancer so our observations here is
that we believe network analysis finds
common biologic processes within complex
traits that network analysis identifies
these processes along the disease
progression path the genes common across
process are classified as controlling
regulation of processes and the biologic
process has identified are both expected
related to energy production and energy
metabolism both critical to well
critical to obesity critical to type 2
diabetes and of course critical to an
oncology cancer phenotype but we also
get some surprising pathway pathway
units like axon guidance or agro
ontology with respect to neural
development so what this may suggest is
that these complex networks are
underlying risk pathways for these
common modern maladies but may be
products of evolutionary adaptation to
other traits that may represent either
mismatch to common environment or
trade-offs to the adapted environment
that drove these networks and our
current common environment so I want to
thank and acknowledge the team that
actually made all this work possible
both my colleagues at ASU my previous
colleagues at the National Cancer
Institute the my colleagues that have
shared with us that korean datasets as
well as thank the contributors to the DB
gap datasets that permit this type of
next-generation data science analysis so
with that I want to close and say that
we are always interested
collaborators partners that people are
interested in participating in these
kinds of studies have interesting
datasets would be interested in learning
how we do these methodologies and apply
them to these complex datasets we'd be
very interested in hearing from you
interacting with you
and exploring how we might apply this
exciting new approach to understanding
these complex traits and their
progression so thank you thank you dr.
buena for the informative presentation
we'll now start the live question the
inter portion of the webinar let's get
started our first question is what are
the limitations of using this network
approach so that's thank you Thank You
audience for that interesting question
network analysis as you might pick up
for my presentation has many strengths
and we're very enthusiastic about its
ability to extend what has been done
with classical G was--or gene
genome-wide Association studies it has
limitations in a number of frames one is
that not all even today not all the
protein coding genes are represented in
biologic networks of biologic pathways
so we don't always have the capacity to
fully interrogate the entire genomic or
genomes except you know m'q
susceptibility space even more so over
and above the protein coding genes many
of the biologic networks as they exist
today don't capture the emerging fields
of micro RNAs or long non-coding rnas or
other regulatory features that could be
driving driving these types of
associations so we're working on a
next-generation
in our lab of exploring how we will
bring together that additional
information into a network context and
stay tuned that'll perhaps be our next
our next webinar for for lab routes next
what's the next question do you have
ideas regarding why pathways would be
common across these datasets I think
that's an interesting question so we
don't really know the underlying you
know why
biologic processes might be more
important than other biologic processes
but not surprisingly given from the
center that I'm from the Center for
evolution and medicine we think there
could be provocative reasons that have
to do with that very early portion of
the talk that I mentioned where we talk
about local adaptation associated with
the development of Jeannette under
changes amongst general genetic
architecture so we what's fascinating to
me is that these phenotypes that we're
looking at obesity diabetes are actually
worldwide common and actually may
represent adaptations that occurred very
early in the human lineage and there's
been speculation that part of this could
be attributable from other authors a
great others that that this may be
attributable today you know human
evolutionary adaptation required for us
to have big brains but the energy
requirements as well as the lipid
requirements and that modifications that
facilitated our evolutionary adaptation
to be the modern humans we are may have
been occurred with the trade-off of
later later age or later life
compromises to our fitness that had no
impact on our reproductive outcomes we
have another one here which is how do
these findings move the field forward
I think there's several applications
that could come from these so one of
them is that they give us novel insights
into the biologic process so so it's an
AB initio discovery process so in this
instance rather than actually having to
look where the light is by doing these
Network processes and by de novo
discovering them we actually have now
clues of the underlying biologic
etiology that may not have occurred from
just standard laboratory investigation
or studying the metabolic process or
other things that we can directly
observe but may not actually be critical
to the to the origins of the disease it
also gives us a foundation so as I
started with the talk earlier I said
that there's no shortage of complexity
associated with the origins of
phenotypes such as obesity and diabetes
but it also now gives us made
some what could become ground truth that
we can now bring into our studies to
evaluate who developed diseases are with
a common under where we can see why some
people who had genetic susceptibility
didn't develop disease or why some
people who had susceptibility did
develop disease given their differences
and exposures okay last question how
might these findings be applied well
it's still early days and as like any
biologic investigation or scientific
investigation what we're seeing here
needs to be validated with additional
datasets and needs to be confirmed with
larger studies but what we think is
interesting a near an immediate
near-term application of these is to do
some flavor of risk stratification to be
able to evaluate who when they obey
phenotype is likely to progress on to
type 2 diabetes so that they can be
differentially focused attentions that
resources can be differentially focused
on those or similarly for those with
type 2 diabetes we could explore and
identify who's at greatest risk of
developing liver cancer or who's at
greatest risk of moving on to a liver
cancer phenotype and then do targeted
screening and other interventions for
those particular components
okay well thank you very much I'll turn
the floor back over to the moderators
thank you we'd like to once again thank
dr. Bhutto for his presentation and I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know about today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August of 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's webinar that's all for now thank
you for joining us
bye bye thank you
you